[Music]
when you realize nothing is lacking the
whole world belongs to you
[Music]
rest and be kind you don't have to prove
anything
[Music]
nothing ever goes away until it has
taught us what we need to know
[Music]
the mind of the beginner is empty free
of the habits of the expert ready to
accept to doubt and open to all the
possibilities
[Music]
wherever you are it's the place you need
to be
[Music]
treat every moment as or last it is not
preparation for something else
[Music]
learn to be comfortable in adversity but
most importantly learn to be comfortable
when you're bored
[Music]
there are only two ways to live your
life
one is as if nothing is a miracle the
other is as if everything is a miracle
[Music]
if you know the enemy and know yourself
you need not fear the result of a
hundred battles
[Music]
respect life revere life
there is nothing more holy than life
nothing more divine than life
our sorrows and wounds are healed only
when we touch them with compassion
[Music]
the good life can be as simple as just
paying attention
[Music]
nature is full of chaos and conflict
don't resist these things
invite them in
[Music]
love is a gift of one's innermost soul
to another so both can be whole
[Music]
the words of the buddha offer this truth
hatred never ceases by hatred but by
love alone is healed
[Music]
just as a mother would protect her only
child with her life even so let one
cultivate a boundless love towards all
beings
[Music]
remember that the best relationship is
one in which your love for each other
exceeds your need for each other
[Music]
friendship is the purest love it is the
highest form of love where nothing is
asked for no condition where one simply
enjoys giving
[Music]
hatred does not cease by hatred but only
by love
[Music]
love is of all passions the strongest
for it attacks simultaneously the head
the heart and the senses
[Music]
if a warrior is not unattached to life
and death he will be of no use
whatsoever
[Music]
peace of mind is that mental condition
in which you have accepted the worst
[Music]
the true miracle is not walking on water
or walking in air but simply walking on
this earth
[Music]
roads were made for journeys not
destinations
[Music]
the personal life deeply lived always
expands into truths beyond itself
when you accept what is every moment is
the best moment
that is enlightenment
not everything happens for a reason
nature is not rational just make peace
with whatever happens
[Music]
the way to free yourself of pain and
suffering is to accept it
[Music]
neither fire nor wind birth nor death
can erase our good deeds
[Music]
the world is afflicted by death and
decay but the wise do not grieve having
realized the nature of the world
[Music]
we all die
the goal isn't to live forever the goal
is to create something that will
[Music]
a man with outward courage dares to die
a man with inner courage dares to live
[Music]
i don't want to die without any scars
[Music]
the search for happiness is one of the
chief sources of unhappiness
[Music]
do not dwell in the past do not dream of
the future concentrate the mind on the
present moment
[Music]
do not let the behavior of others
destroy your inner peace
[Music]
if you want happiness for a year inherit
a fortune if you want happiness for a
lifetime help someone else
[Music]
there is no need for temples no need for
complicated philosophy our own brain our
own heart is our temple the philosophy
is kindness
thousands of candles can be lit from a
single candle and the life of the candle
will not be shortened
happiness never decreases by being
shared
[Music]
be kind whenever possible it is always
possible
[Music]
we do not exist for the suck of
something else we exist for the sack of
ourselves
[Music]
to be beautiful means to be yourself
you don't need to be accepted by others
you need to accept yourself
[Music]
do not follow the idea of others but
learn to listen to the voice within
yourself
[Music]
[Laughter]
happiness lies even in little tiny
butterflies you just have to open up
your eyes and see where beauty flies to
beautify your world lengthwise
[Music]
you